the most difficult visual effect shots
we've ever done we need precise help
with this quiet on set hold hold hold
break an angle break a wrist
trim tech two the sequel to our now most
viewed video of all time first one was
the zombie meat harvester this one
they're crafting a zombie killer
motorcycle machine boom the guys from
super 73 come by our studio and they're
like hey we want you to trap these mini
bikes they're electric
we need them to make us a stripped
version that doesn't actually have
pedals or chains on it when you want to
shoot this i'm going on two weeks he's
like ah
okay you ready let's reveal it dude i i
i'm so excited i'm so excited
thanks for putting this thing together
ready
natty reactions
oh i don't want to mess this up
that's so nice
look at these handlebars
dude
these foot pegs here are also bolted on
so you can remove them oh that's
suspension
wow
dude this is a cool looking little mini
bike right now
this is yeah
this is incredible ruroc likes our stuff
and so they handed us one of these
really sweet looking helmets so we got
the primtech bike it looks super sick
but with primtech videos comes some of
the most difficult visual effects shots
we've ever done at corridor there's one
shot in particular where i essentially
build the bike frame out of bamboo
sticks there's so many things going on
in this one shot it's gonna take hours
hopefully the lighting stays consistent
for us to actually be able to use all
the plates that we shoot but we honestly
won't know until tomorrow everything
everything's good to go pretty much you
hear the sound of that
that's the sound of jared working on the
the the arch that's not done yet for
tomorrow
i'm about an inch down yes because it's
starting fires every time i drill into
it
it's smoking
i even tried to dig out some and then
get going again but use your arms real
strong in that grip because i don't want
it's been ripping on me it hurts here
here
has done that to me a few times yeah
break break an angle break a wrist
unexpected problem let's try the other
bit
there we go
yeah yeah it's sharper for sure it looks
like
yeah this one good because i was really
worried yeah take it slow yeah
we're going for two inches yeah
i was concerned last week i had i sort
of had a panic attack mid last week
thinking that we wouldn't be able to get
all this done in time we worked our
butts off the last couple of days and
now jared's putting the finishing
touches on some things making these red
tires look like intestines
it's 7am we've got everything ready the
bike's done the builds are ready let's
go see how this all comes together now
on set so okay it's no surprise well
obviously the primtech videos and the
memo video are related right how could
they not be like we're wearing the same
costumes they're both apocalyptic kind
of realized okay this is actually
happening after the meemaw video mima
origins lima origins welcome to prim
tech 2. we're shooting these shots in
that weird backwards order because we
have lots of plates that we're going to
be taking and compositing once that
camera's set it's just trying to
minimize anyone walking on the set
because any little movement or
difference in shots could potentially
make things difficult for us last time
was really really fun this video was
really cool and everyone on the internet
liked it so hopefully this uh recreates
a little bit of that magic also
let's be mindful of like everyone's safe
there's like a knife in that box
um if we ask you guys to do anything
that you don't feel comfortable doing
just be like nah that's okay and we'll
figure out a different way to do it
especially for the zombies so did you
see that guys dude
with an open knife in a box look there's
a bunch of spikes on the ground and i
have to be barefoot in camps are they
actually spikes or is it stinging nettle
they're spikes
you know when you fall into a pit and
there's spikes
it's like it's like micro spikes they're
baby super tiny ah
it's called stinging nettle i hear it's
not that bad though it's terrible like i
i hit my wrist on it trying to clear a
trail and it was miserable son you're
overthinking this no no i think it's
going to be perfect you can make it
actually why do you have this part you
do not need this part no it's going to
be perfect nobody that's going to
restrict so much motion hold on
first dude son what are you doing these
shoes though
as a man who had to run around in
nothing but socks for an entire video
let me give you a small piece of advice
stop what you're doing take a take a
marker outline your foot put the
cardboard on the bottom of your foot
secure it and then cover the tape with
leather straps it works i'm really
worried about clint
you guys making a forest yes making a
bamboo forest this is um this is how god
did it creating a bamboo forest yeah in
the middle of a non-bamboo forest
[Music]
i got this uh exhaust so to simulate
smoke we're gonna use this smoke bomb
the idea jake is that we're gonna be
able to pull it from a rip cord i don't
know how strong this is though
apparently fire's gonna come out of
these hands
[Music]
yeah not much time but enough for a shot
we got a bunch of them we got like 12 so
out of jank
comes glory i'm trying to delay as long
as possible putting on any sort of like
zombie makeup
plenty of blood and dirt your first
victim has arrived yeah i'm zombie
number two actually okay oh yeah i got
my zombie face on lock though
you ever played a zombie before i have
not played a zombie before it's uh
pretty new got kind of excited
i just feel like a sultan over here do i
look good you're next
ring we've actually gotten two takes
already i've officially been nettled
and you're okay and it stings like crazy
action
rolling
and acting
perfect all right we're good uh light
wise and action
action
so um this video takes a lot of
composition meaning lots of different
plates you're doing a lot of different
shots that stack up on each other and so
things can't change between the shots so
you're going to notice the difference
you need like that kind of perfect
overlap so if it's shadowy in one shot
it's not going to comp with the sunny
shot so basically whatever the first
shot of the plates are whether it's
overcast we have to commit to the rest
of the ways being our guys for this
specific sequence we're committing to
overcast so every shot has to be
overcast waiting for a little overcast
the next one could be all sunny um it
just really depends on
the weather and the clouds rolling this
is for real one take
hold on cut done i'm gonna look at the
clouds just got bright again all right
now yeah we're good for a good chunk all
right let's do it here we go rolling
and
action
hold hold hold hold hold cut
quiet on set please
you look dead dude i feel alive
you excited show me your zombies face
come on
weak sauce ah dude i like threw out my
neck last time i played a zombie when i
was doing all like all this stuff and
that was like
how about it i remember how much of a of
a ordeal it was last time she's giving
me veins i'm gonna be so strong
god
it wasn't the makeup oh that's fine it's
the hair gel yeah dude in about an hour
or so it's gonna harden up to the point
that it's like super hard like basically
a helmet
like i can be like riding my onewheel
and like crashing
whoa
that primitive technology time machine
really works because now we're in the
middle ages so now it's time to tell you
guys about something special we're doing
here at corridor called the tournament
of champions for the next four videos
the episode sponsor of that video will
have two members of the corridor crew
fight for the right to represent that
sponsor in a final tournament of
champions to be determined at the spring
festival now it's rumored that king sam
ii will be in attendance himself and
will determine the champion right then
and there so in this episode we have two
knights sir nico and sir red put this
other way put that the other way sir red
is new to fighting
and they're going to be fighting today
for the right to represent lady audible
that's right today's episode is brought
to you by the wonderful folks at audible
let's commence i really want to win this
is my true love wren believe in yourself
but i'm going to beat you and let the
battle for lady audible begin
[Laughter]
come on nico
[ __ ]
in celebration of that first point i
just want to say that you can get your
first book for free when you try audible
for 30 days go to audible.com corridor
crew or text corridor crew to 500 500.
now we think the tournament of champions
is special not only just for us but for
you and here's why if you're already
signed up for audible in this video
leave a comment if you sign up for
audible because of this video leave a
comment because if audible wins in the
final tournament of champions we're
gonna be going back and picking one
person from the comments and giving them
the rest of 2019 free for that service
it's on us comments
a subscription also gives you access to
audible originals which are exclusive
titles from some of the world's most
celebrated storytellers
let's go again nico where's my helmet
comments
i would never survive in the ring
oh god
oh
god audible gives you an unmatched
selection of audiobooks unlike a
streaming service you own your books
just like i'm owning ren
the next one's for the win boys round
four begin
go to audible.com slash quarter crew
attracts quarter crew to 500 500. he's
obviously the champion of this
tournament so he'll be representing
audible in the final tournament but
before he does that remember to leave a
comment if you're already using audible
or if you sign up using this video
because you could get the rest of 2019
for free nico what's your book man my
book recommendation is stephen king's
11.22.63
a time traveling story about this
assassination of jfk and a man trying to
stop it in the consequences of such an
event wait does it change time travel it
does
we better get back to that prim deck
video boys
since this shoot is very camera setup
oriented sam and clint will sit there
set up the camera talk about exactly how
they're gonna work through a shot
there's a lot of time before that to get
all the art that we need in place the
shots themselves are so composed that
each one is sort of its own artistic
composition the shot clown people it's
freaking crazy this is like probably the
most advanced shot we've got in this
whole thing man wait let me walk you
through it so basically i come here i
draw a blueprint of the bike frame in
the ground with this spear i grab pieces
of bamboo throw them down into position
that position it's not going to be
thrown down exactly like this so once i
throw them down i leave frame for some
reason we have to figure out where to
justify why i'm leaving frame as i leave
frame we come in and perfectly drop
these sticks and we get we record plates
of all these sticks landing i come back
in to frame it'll just be like a second
right i come back in
and
from here
let me explain let me explain the first
shot which is not hard at all is clint
steps in the frame he draws a blueprint
of this thing he's going to make steps
out of frame we hide a cut while anyways
a bunch of [ __ ] happens you don't
need to worry about it shot two we start
with a pile of sticks on the ground in a
similar configuration to this they are
going to be loose and not bound like
this
he goes through and pretends like he
acts like he's binding him all together
he runs out of strips and he's going to
walk over here and steal my shirt and
convert this into cloth strips he
magically binds them with cloth strips
when he applies his last cloth strip it
magically turns into the full bike okay
in order to do this what we're gonna do
is something that's a little complicated
and we need precise
help with this okay because it's all
just again stacking shots on top of each
other composing them to be one shot but
a lot of things going on looks like
we're to go with overcast because it's
easier
but right now we're lacking our class so
all right we're overcast for a good show
we're very much in clouds definitely
here we go let's do a take we only get
one shot at this rolling
action
[Applause]
cool and
pit crew let's do this everyone hold so
jared's coming in derek's going in watch
your shadows everybody your shadows
clear the excess ones yeah you got that
wrap right there let's spray
okay clear your hands
give yourself some distance from the top
rod jared
there you go
three two one
two one
perfect all right guys hold it and then
now uh jared i need you on to guide yep
perfect so just yeah pick up basically
right on the mark
that's convenient
that's great
looking good
back it this way an inch
yeah
um
yeah that looks right okay clear three
two one go
[Music]
oh
nice
teamwork there's no take two
you only get one shot
good work guys that was the most
complicated shot we're gonna shoot today
i just got dirty
yeah like clap right there
well another video done and in the can
as they say so we're gonna take this
back into the lab and see how it all
cuts together see if what we thought we
were creating on set actually matches
what we're intending to do in post we'll
be doing at least one video on the
process of how we actually make this
thing come to life in post so stay
subscribed if you're not already because
that's coming up and also huge thanks to
super 73 for hooking up the awesome
custom made electric mini bike